et nous accueillons neutralité du samedi
20 heures ce soir latifa il baigne
athènes bonsoir
alors latifa liens non votre fils soldat
imad ibenge athènes tombés sous les
balles de mohamed merah et dans les
jours suivants le terroriste abate six
autres personnes dont trois enfants
quelques semaines après la mort de votre
fils vous décidez d'aller visiter le
quartier dans lequel mohamed merah a
grandi et là vous découvrez que le
terroriste est un héros de l'islam
depuis vous allez retrouver un sens à
votre vie vous avez décidé de porter
secours à ces jeunes tenté par le diable
vous nous raconterez votre histoire à 20
heures
je
[Musique]
natif à re bonsoir vous êtes né à
tétouan au maroc le 1er janvier 1960
votre père était trompettiste dans
l'armée espagnole et votre mère femme au
foyer
mais comme votre père est très coureurs
votre mère finit par obtenir le divorce
et elle quitte le maroc pour chiquita
qui est une enclave espagnole sur la
côte méditerranéenne à côté de melilla
voilà avec d'ailleurs ses enfants c'est
là qu'elle rencontre son second mari qui
lui se comporte très bien et vous paye
l'école espagnole ça c'est une bonne
période pour vous latifa quelque chose
quand je pourrai pas oublié hélas vous
avez neuf ans lorsque votre mère meurt
vous vous retrouvez avec votre soeur
chez votre père à tanger hélas la
nouvelle épouse de votre père vous
traitent comme des domestiques et vous
interdit d'aller à l'école
mais c'est la souffrance de ne pas aller
à l'école ne pas apprendre c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui que je quand je vois les
enfants rient et quand tu n'es pas les
urnes aux études que j'ai dû moi j'ai
pas eu de chance ouais ce n'est qu'à 13
ans que vous serez secouru par une tante
vous dit mes mains étaient violette et
plein de cloques ont dû travailler
vraiment comme une esclave pour votre
belle mère mais nous allons utiliser
parce que comme on n'avait pas de mère
mon père est toujours absent et la
profité de moi et ma soeur de servir
comme une bonne chez elle et chez sa
famille à 14 ans vous évader de cet
univers vous partez travailler en usine
il ya une période assez heureuse parce
que vous fréquentez un peu des gens des
gens de lusine les directeurs de lusine
tout ça c'est la nostalgie de ma
jeunesse ouais j'ai découvert
une manière européen oui malheureusement
votre grand frère
fini par avoir les moyens de subvenir
vos besoins et il vous dit de rentrer à
la maison ils vous interdit de
travailler
ça c'était dur à 16 ans vous rencontrez
votre future marée qui bosse à la sncf
en france et un an plus tard donc à 17
ans vous le rejoignez en france à
sotteville les rouen c'est de vous faire
à chaque angle est arrivé non c'était
trop dur radio 1 c'est une ville qui
parle pas je ne chante pas celle ci
lance
alors là devant l'ennui qui vous
submerge vous décidé de nouer des
relations avec vos voisines et puis
surtout d'apprendre le français
vous vous dites c'est la seule façon de
trouver du travail si je veux me sortir
de là il faut que je parle bien le
français ça c'était le besoin
absolument fallait que j'apprends la
langue pour parler avec mes voisins avec
mes amis sortir de trouver ma liberté
c'était important
cet apprentissage du français vous
permettra d'envoyer vos enfants à
l'école et alors ce qui est fou c'est
que quand on vous fait de faire les
devoirs à vos enfants en fait vous
connaissez pas très bien donc vous leur
dites des fausses faute parce que vous
ne savez pas en fait et il fallait
montrer que je savais il fallait garder
ce secret est que mes enfants vous avez
une maman phase ii et j'ai trouvé une
faute sans faute ouais voilà alors vous
voulez farouchement vous intégrer à la
société française dit à la maison vivait
comme des français vous fêtez les fêtes
catholiques ou se tait noël et à
l'extérieur vous voulez que vos enfants
fréquentent des français de souche ou
les vraiment de sortir de votre milieu
je vais en france j'aime c'est payé j'ai
fondé une famille et il fallait que je
vive normalement tout le monde de
culture de richesse
c'était important vous les obliger pas à
faire le ramadan à vos enfants on ne
doit pas obliger nos enfants on doit
laisser la liberté et c'est là qu'un jeu
votre fils imad celui qui était le plus
proche de vous ça veut dire plus
imad nous annonce qu'il va s'engager
dans l'armée dont il devient
parachutistes et il participera à un
certain nombre d'opérations l'opération
épervier au tchad et l'opération licorne
en côte d'ivoire
et un jour il vous dit tu sais maman il
se pourrait que je meure avant toi
mais c'était difficile ça ce jour là
c'est quelque chose que je ne pourrai
jamais oublier là aussi une assurance et
on me dit voilà s'il m'arrive quelque
chose moment surtout monterrey chez moi
moi j'ai déchets doit si si vous m'aidez
bachy vous si le pied d'origine et jeudi
c'est moi de mourir avant pas à fond de
toi et me dire lors quand on arrive on
n'a pas
et donc ils vous demandent de l'intérêt
on dit qu à quelques kilomètres de
tétouan donc au maroc
et puis le vendredi 9 mars 2012 vous
êtes en voyage en turquie avec votre
mari c'est votre fille cimade qui vous a
offert le voyage
vous le sentez nerveuse angoissé vous
n'aimez pas tellement l'hôtel où vous
avez vous trouvé le lugubre cet hôtel
j'avais un sentiment ce jour là c'est
quelque chose la standing mer j'avais un
couteau dans le coeur way et rim est
cette heure-là il était mort
sortie à konya et l'appareil vous avez
un sentiment d'oppression vous dites
comme si j'étais à l'intérieur d'une
tombe alors qu'à ce moment là vous ne
savez pas encore que votre fils est mort
vous rentrer à l'hôtel et c'est là que
votre autre fils à steam vous appelle et
vous annonce que votre fils a été tué
par mohamed mer
on ne sait pas encore à ce moment là
mais il tuera encore deux militaires à
montauban quatre civils à toulouse l
école juive ozar hatorah dont trois
enfants
alors ce qui est terrible c'est
l'accueil des policiers toulousains
quand vous allez reconnaître le corps de
votre fils parce qu'il commence par vous
dire mais votre fils c'était un
délinquant c'était un trafic enfin comme
si le fait d'être arabe musulman était
obligatoirement lié à ça on était très
humilié j'ai pas encore vu mon fils elle
est la morgue oui j'étais pas encore sûr
que c'était lui et ses policiers il me
parlait comme
sans coeur sans être humain et c'est
quelque chose que je ne peux pas oublier
et il vous dit même un de vos garçons
est il capable de tuer son frère
jeudi messieurs s'il vous plaît ouais
c'est trop dur qui vous venez de dire
laisse moi par mon fils de mort le
lendemain vous allez à la morgue et vous
découvrez que votre fils a été autopsié
sans votre autorisation
ça c'est un choc total parce que mon
fils il est mort et l'on salue sa
mémoire ouais et d'aller à l'hôpital me
dire madame préparez vous ouais votre
fils rien topsy là c'est quelque chose
quand j'ai touché mon fils ouais c'était
quelque chose de trop aux yeux vous
passer plusieurs jours à la morgue oui
assure jours plusieurs
pratiquement tous les gens j'allais le
voir et ce policier quand je les demande
et je posais cette question pourquoi
vous avez fait cette autopsie sont
demandés il me dit madame gardez votre
calme
si vous continuez à parler comme ça je
vais raccrocher c'est là que j'ai
répondu jeudi me succès c'est ma chère
qu'ils sont la table c'est pas la vôtre
le 22 mars 2012 mohamed merah est abattu
par les hommes du raid vous vous auriez
préféré qu'il soit traduit en justice
oki bus
s'expliquer et qu'on lui pose un certain
nombre de questions sur son geste bien
sûr c'était important pour nous mouais
pour toutes les familles
très important alors vous allez au maroc
enterrer votre fils donc la rime dit
qu'à côté de tétouan et là vous êtes
obligés d'appeler la chaîne qatarie al
djazira parce qu'il voulait diffuser les
images de la tuerie tourné par mohamed
mer
quelque chose horrible troisième jour de
jeu l'intérêt monfils way est d'aller le
matin sur sa tombe et je ressens qu'au
téléphone des sages appelée au secours à
tout le monde j'appelais le qatar j'ai
appelé la générale j'appelais la france
le roi du maroc ça c'est quelque chose
je dis alors si vous montrez ça vous
verrez ma mort sur la conscience et ça
je te prête
et j'ai toujours peur jusqu'à maintenant
mais pourquoi il voulait diffuser cette
vidéo à désirant
c'est ça que je comprends pas et vous
voyez qu'un assassin tué trois religions
oui trois adultes là dessus des enfants
il a touché quand même la france parce
que c'était soldats bien sûr qu'il vit
convient d'en montrer des choses comme
si très ambigu l'attitude du qatar dans
tout ça non
et là un jour vous êtes assise sur la
tombe de votre fils et vous avez une
espèce d'illumination vous décidé de
sauver ce qu'ils ont fait subir ce sort
à votre fils jeudi faut que je rencontre
où il habitait mère à qui les merengues
et quand je suis allé sur moi ces jeunes
si je les ai dit ce que mes race est un
héros oui ces martyrs des excuses il a
ni la france entière à genoux donc ils
sont fiers de lui
et quand j'ai parlé avec ces jeunes et
je les compte j'ai expliqué je me suis
présenté je vous assure et en changer en
vous leur dites clip vous êtes
effectivement et ils vous disent on vit
comme des rats et les rats quand ils
sont enfermés il devienne enragé
ceci étant permettez moi de vous dire et
de leur dire que si tous les gens qui
vivaient dans des cités tiré à bout
portant autour des militaires des
enfants juifs
donc vous leur dites mais vos parents et
qu'est ce qu'ils disent quand vous dites
que mohamed merah est un héros etc et
ils disent nous nos parents de façon
leur en parle pas et si nos parents nous
voyez crever finalement ils seraient pas
mécontents j'ai répondu non c'est pas
possible
à chaque maire et lemm son enfant c'est
parce que il meurt quand et réagissent
où ils répondent comme ça son enfant
parce qu'elle n'est pas contente l'ebita
ce qu'il fait alors en mai 2012 vous
lancez une structure dead aux jeunes
vous dites je veux sauver ceux qui sont
à l'origine de mes souffrances c'est
magnifique
quand j'étais au site et j'avais vu ces
jeunes sont perdus ouais sont livrés à
eux mêmes ils manquent de dents fiction
et manque d'être cadré il y manque plein
de choses dont 6 gb s et on peut les
récupérer il faut les entendre qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire la diva il faut les
aider foulée cadres et et pour l'aider à
faire des formations des stages on doit
pas fermer les yeux ce que vous savez un
jeune rien qu'ils regardent ça parle
ouais on doit pas tourner le dos si on
le laisse comme ça cela devient des
bêtes sauvages oui on doit les aider
parce que ils se sont pas quand ils sont
en france ce sont pas 600 français quand
il parle le pays d'origine et savent pas
six ans ouais sont perdus lors des plus
d'autorité de la part des parents et
certains parents qu'ils ont oublié la
leçon je pense qu'ils ont oublié
l'éducation au centre est moi je
j'approche beaucoup aux parents parce
que les parents ils sont responsables de
leurs enfants ouais
[Applaudissements]
testing ordinaire cet acte de pardon des
assassins de son fils ça c'est
extrêmement nous on dirait chrétien
c'est c'est superbe c'est sublime bravo
[Applaudissements]
latifa vous raconter cette histoire dans
un livre qui s'appelle mans pour la
france qui sort le 6 mars chez
flammarion merci de votre témoignage
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu